city councilwoman kelly wants to know
how the residents of her district feel
about a proposed school redistricting
plan which of the following survey
methods will allow Councilwoman Kelly to
make a valid conclusion about how
residents of her district feel about the
proposed plan so before we even look at
these we have to realize that if you're
trying to make a valid conclusion about
how the residents of her entire district
feel about the proposed plan she has to
find a representative sample or not kind
of a skewed sample that would just
sample parts of her district so let's
look at her choices should she just ask
her neighbors
well her neighbor she might live in a
part of the neighborhood that might
unusually benefit from the redistricting
plan or might get hurt from the
redistricting plan and so just her
neighbors wouldn't be representative of
the district as a whole so just asking
her neighbors probably does not make
sense ask the residents of Whispering
Pines retirement community so once again
this is not the first ones cused by
geography she's she's over sampling her
neighbors and not the entire district
here she's over sampling a specific age
demographic so he or she is she's over
sampling ret older residents who might
have very different opinions than middle
aged or younger residents so that
doesn't make sense either ask 200
residents of her district whose names
are chosen at random well that seems
reasonable it doesn't seem like you know
there's some chance that you somehow
oversample one direction or another but
it's most likely to give a reasonably
representative sample this is a pretty
large sample size so it's important to
say what is the random process where is
she getting these names from but this
actually does seem reasonable ask a
group of parents at the local playground
well once again this is just like asking
asking your neighbors and it's also
sampling a specific demographic now this
might be the demographic that cares most
about the schools but that she wants to
know how her whole district feels about
the redistricting plan and once ago this
is at a local playground this isn't that
you know all the playgrounds in the
district somehow so I wouldn't do this
one either
let's do one more of these Mimi wants to
conduct a survey of her 300 classmates
to determine which candidate
for class president Napoleon Dynamite or
Blair Worrell Waldorf is in the lead of
the upcoming election Mimi will ask the
question if the election were today
which candidate would get your vote
which of the following methods of
surveying her classmates will allow me
me to make valid conclusions about which
candidate is in the lead so let's see
ask all of the students at Blair's lunch
table no that would skew it in Blair's
favor probably that's not a
representative sample ask all the
members of Napoleon's soccer team no
same thing they're likely to go to poll
Ian's way or maybe they don't like
Napoleon maybe they'll go against
Napoleon but either way this seems like
a skewed sample put the names of all the
students in a hat and draw 50 names ask
those students whose names are drawn
well this seems like a nice random
sample that could be nicely
representative of the entire population
ask all students whose names begin with
N or B well this could be perceived as
kind of random but notice n is the same
starting letter as Napoleon B is the
same starting letterblair you might say
well that's fair you're doing it for
each of their letters but maybe there's
like 10 people whose name start with an
N and only two people whose names start
with a B once again you're not even
getting a large sample and then on top
of that maybe there's some type of
people with the same starting letter
somehow like each other more so I would
I would steer clear of this one ask
every student in the class well that
would work
you know there's 300 classmates that
might not be that time-consuming and
that would be pretty good you can't get
a better sample than asking everyone in
the population which of the following
methods of surveying your classmates
will allow me me to make a valid
conclusion about which candidate is in
the lead well that's a pretty good
conclusion people might change their
mind so it's not a done deal but that's
you can't get a better sample size than
the entire population assign numbers to
each student each students each student
in the class and use a computer program
to generate 50 random numbers between 1
and 300 ask those students whose numbers
are selected well this is pretty close
to put the names of all the students in
a hat and draw 50 names so I would give
this one that seems reasonable as well